[Applaudissements]
valérie franchement c'est un très bel
âne hajaoui bien sûr enfin très bel
alliage d'ailleurs merci vous avez vous
êtes d'origine espagnole comme manuel
valls web alors l'espagnol aussi c'est
que la vie tourne espagnol dit tout un
truc voilà soyez un petit peu sensuelle
en espagnol dites-nous cyril dit mme
cyrine j'ai envie de passer la nuit avec
vous s'il vous les voulez vous dise
après non moi j'ai envie de dire quelque
chose d'aussi l'asie
[Applaudissements]
valérie benaïm vous allez nous leur
faire l'espagnol est vrai que c'est pas
mal du tout le palais valérie parce que
pouvez-nous dire en espagnol ce soir
avant de me coucher je vais me
déshabiller lentement là la comédie lui
n'importe quoi
[Rires]
et un autre chez non mais voilà qui
talent lovett amène bensari enti battu
mais d'autres sortir
[Applaudissements]